so the heading is volume of a sphere and
on the board and love for you in your
book I've drawn a circle this is a
circle right now but watch this I'm
about to make it a sphere now if you got
a sphere as attractive as mine the
volume of the sphere has a really
unusual formula to it but before I show
you we need to add a little bit on to
our diagram here on the sphere it's more
like a prism in that if I cut it at any
different point I'm not going to get the
same shape every time I'm going to get
different shapes
however whichever way you cut it if you
cut across you're going to get a circle
okay now what I want to do is if you can
draw it in for me right in the middle
the center of the sphere if we went all
the way around this sphere right in the
middle okay so if this was the earth I
guess what we'd be looking at is the
well hold on just this line I mean I've
got yeah I've got hemisphere into this
with you this line would be in Quetta
alone so this equator right remember I
said to you if you cut the circle in
this direction you'll get a whole bunch
of different circles if you cut higher
or lower though do you notice you don't
have to draw this part cause your
diagram will get very busy but if you
drew one on the top do you notice the
circle be smaller who is that
like if you're right in the middle
that's the biggest circle you can
possibly get so we call this because
it's the biggest one we give a special
name we call it a great circle and the
equator is a great circle on the earth
okay where as for instance if you go
look at the top if this were the earth
that might be something like the Arctic
Circle it's still circle but it's
definitely not the biggest one so in
order to measure this thing we need the
Great Circle and we need its radius just
like a circle on the sphere only has
one dimension that really matters so if
I say this is the radius it's not just
any radius it's the radius of a great
circle then the volume formula looks
like this okay now I just like to go on
record to say at this point in time as a
u10 student I remember this is one of
the weirdest formulas to remember it's
quite easy to get it wrong it's sort of
like what is that 4/3 what is up with
that what is it doing there
I just want to point out that just like
we've the volume of a cone and printer
pyramids in future and if you to master
X approach everyone in this room in
future you will learn why this lumbers
is what it is and why it seems to have a
smooth serious connection do you
remember the surface area of a sphere we
looked at very briefly I showed you a
podium or very good for circles we know
every circle is PI R square now I wonder
if you squint do you notice these guys
have to be related in some way and they
are in a really really surprising way
but there's a lot a lot of mathematic
you have to develop before that makes
sense for now this is the formula that I
like you to have in your mind for the
big colorful box around it and let's
just simply have an idea of how to use
it here I've got three simple setups
I've drawn their pictures because every
speaker looks like every other sphere
okay every single one is similar to all
the road so that one over there that's
just gonna be our sphere for this
question if I have a piece of
information like say the radius I can
use that to work out the body really
simple straight substitution in this
case the volume will be 4/3 pi times 5
cubed I did
5 cubed is 125 or 4 times 125 by pink is
500 now I'm just going to use this as an
opportunity to point something out would
you put your pens down forever
occasionally not very often but
occasionally rather than like in the
first in the review questions I asked
you to approximate I said hey can you
give this to me one decimal place two
decimal places etc occasionally you'll
be asked to provide data and they want
you to leave it precise they don't want
you to approximate they want to exact
not like ten decimal places or 20
perfectly so what I've done here 500 PI
on three that's it
that is the exact volume if they then
want you to approximate you're of course
gonna put this into your calculator what
are you going to get when you put it in
and someone already calculated by any
chance yeah five twenty three point one
five was it five million okay
so for all intents and purposes let's
just go one decimal place I don't know
if you've seen before but the
approximately equal sign is two of them
this is one of them it's what I like
it's too wavy lines so I'm going to do
one decimal place does anyone know what
the other approximately equal sign is it
looks like a regular equal sign except
it has two dots and once you see it
maybe you can tell what I don't like
this one and I prefer this one when you
do this one if you like just do really a
little ones it just looks like a normal
equal sign right it's very easy to
mistake like when you press a dog it's
quite easy to just look like that so
that's why this works okay let's have a
look at oh yeah question Olivia
like simplified it you mean went to this
if they didn't ask for it at this point
it wouldn't really matter but it's
paying attention to whether they say
give me the exact that's exact or give
it to me wonderful place two dozen
places whatever if they didn't specify
really I mean to be honest have a look
at the way I've set out this answer do
you notice the first thing I did was
here's the exact one and then I went to
my calculator and I did the impossible
one if they didn't ask for a particular
way look I've got both I'm clearly
demonstrating the skill to be able to do
both so how are you gonna take marks on
me right so therefore I think this is
the best way to go but just read the
question and tell you alright I have a
look at this one it just doesn't take
too much thinking but it is phrased
slightly differently if you've been
given the diameter can I put that in
here I can't because the diameter is
exactly twice the radius so the first
thing I'm going to do is work out what
the radius is so carve it and now I can
use the formula because the formula is
all about the radius so I'm not even
going to actually work it out but I'll
show you the way that I would put 4/3 pi
times 50 squared cubed sorry and off you
go
okay by the way just a quick note the
powers remember this one's surface area
and there's a two this one is volume and
there's a three why is that
think big thing they are different who
said that you say to get an out of cake
please
fantastic this is a three-dimensional
space this surface area it's a two
dimensional space so that's why it's a
two that's why it's a three and even
though I just got that wrong I fix
myself up because I knew was volume is
three days you can work out what that is
last question if you get given the
volume instead we can reverse this
process and find out the radius or the
diameter if we so choose so why don't
you keep it simple for now if I told you
the volume this is like the cylinder
question I gave you before how would I
go about finding the radius what would I
write okay very good so this is the
volume which has been given to me so
I've put this over my left hand side
because I do want the are eventually to
be on the left hand side so I might as
well put on the left hand side to be
doing okay then I need to divide both
sides so let's see if I divide both
sides what am i I wanted to by boy I
will divide by PI what I've studied to
divide by 4/3 as well so I'm just gonna
there's gonna be the whole thing at once
I'm gonna let the calculator take care
so I'm gonna go 541 divided by 4/3 pi I
know it's a little bit messy having a
fraction inside a fraction but to be
honest the calculator would just eat
that for breakfast he doesn't get it so
Liz you incorrectly yeah now let's
actually whip it up can you tell me
what's the readout in your calculator
when you pull it 541
can you do the function button and put
4/3 PI on the bottom can you do it
one hundred and twenty nine point one
five four three thumbs up and so I'm
giving this one hundred twenty nine
point whatever if that number is what
I've got off the right hand side don't
forget that's not the radius what is
that ah look again at the left hand side
right this is what's so important you
write both sides of the equation this is
not the radius this is the radius cubed
so on your calculator what if you got to
do undo that ah be super careful if you
have a look on my calculator above the
square root button you can see in yellow
there's the cube root button okay so
what you're gonna have to do with that
number still there is go shift square
root you'll know it's different because
the calculator display online looks like
this right so that three is how you know
you're taking the cube root not the
square root once you've done that can I
get a number five point five point zero
what 0-5 dot dot dot cool that's right
and you guys can watch later and that's
it what are the units by the way now
this is a length so therefore it's one
dimensional so it's just a minute